détendu et souriant
voilà l'image projetée par rogers stone
proches flamboyant donald trump est
reconnu coupable de sept chefs
d'accusation dont mensonge au congrès et
subornation de témoin dans la sphère de
l'ingérence russe lors des élections de
la grande question combien de temps
va-t-il passer en prison dès à présent 3
4 ans ou jusqu'à 9 ans comme le
réclamait initialement les procureurs au
dossier
il ya une semaine donald trump étaient
passés à l'attaqué sur twitter pour
défendre son ami rogers stone parlant d'
erreur judiciaire
le lendemain le procureur général
william moore suggéré à son tour une
peine moins sévère
il n'en fallait pas plus pour que donald
trump le félicite d'être intervenu
de quoi jeter le doute sur
l'impartialité du département de la
justice
face à un président autoritaire
aujourd'hui après plus de deux heures
d'argumentation
la juge amy jackson a fait tomber le
couperet rogers stone sera emprisonné
pendant trois ans et quatre mois et
devra payer une amende de 20000 dollars
elle a déclaré que rogers stone n'a pas
été poursuivi pour avoir défendu le
président mais bien pour l'avoir couvert
et pour déterminer la peine
la juge a également pris en
considération l'âge de stone 67 ans raj
stone et maintenant le président va-t-il
voler à la rescousse de son proche ami
en lui accordant le pardon présidentiel
ou en réduisant sa peine
oui un gaming m quelques heures après le
prononcé de la peine de stone et
s'exprimant devant des anciens détenus
qui ont eu une deuxième chance
trump déclare jouera jazz avait pas de
pardon présidentiel pour l'instant de la
part de donald trump le temps dit il que
d'autres procédures devant les tribunaux
suivent leur cours
les il estime qu'il y a de fortes
chances que rogers tonnes soit blanchi
d'une façon ou d'une autre
ici frédéric arnould radio-canada
washington